[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 86 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing.
MARK MANDEL: I am good.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Back from Denver for GopherCon,
enjoying the beautiful weather
in San Francisco,
while you are in--
MARK MANDEL: Very warm
weather in New York.
It's lovely here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very, very,
very warm weather in New York,
I'm sure.
MARK MANDEL: I feel like
it's appropriately warm.
I really like warm weather.
San Francisco is never
quite warm enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I disagree.
But anyway, today we're going
to have a really interesting
conversation with, actually,
two people from two
very different areas.
One is a Googler and manages
platinum customer account.
And the other one is an
engineer from Broad Institute,
which happens to be
a platinum customer.
And they're going to be
telling us all about what
does it mean to be a
platinum customer, what
are the benefits, what
kind of things they do.
It is really interesting.
We've been having a couple
episodes on, like, SRE and CRE,
and how customers and
Googlers partner into, like,
their ventures.
So we're going to keep on
talking about that, basically.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's a really
interesting conversation
about the multitude of
ways that Google Cloud
Platform and Google itself
can help customers of ours
to help be successful,
which is quite cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And some cool stories at
the end of the episode.
And at the end, after
those cool stories,
we'll have the question
of the week, as usual.
And this time comes
from GopherCon.
Actually, someone came up to
the Google Cloud Platform booth
that we had, and
they asked a question
about how to do it to
basically expose a Kubernetes'
service without having to pay
for a load balancer, which
makes sense only for
very tiny clusters, for,
like, QA and stuff like that.
But it's definitely cool at the
end, good to know how to do it.
So we'll cover that at the end.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
Well, why don't we get
stuck into our cool things
of the week?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
The first one, even
though, is about Europe--
and I am definitely
European-- is about something
that I do not know that much.
So I'm going to let
you go and explain
to us what this really means.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So the top of the story
is that we now have
a new region open in London.
So another region in urban
Europe, which is pretty cool.
We have a few more still
coming in Finland, Netherlands,
and Frankfurt.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And we've
got a variety of products
from there, from auto scalers to
Container Engine to App Engine
to Data Lab, et cetera.
I think the
interesting part here--
and I am definitely
not a lawyer,
so I would redirect
you to the show notes
so you can read the
article properly.
We did write a blog post
recently announcing basically
our commitment to the General
Data Protection Regulation,
which takes effect in May 2018.
For those of you
who aren't familiar,
it's basically privacy
legislation that
goes into effect across Europe.
And so we want to
make sure that that's
good for all our
European customers.
Again, I'm not a
lawyer, so I'm going
to redirect you to the blog
post to read through it all.
It'll be in the show notes.
But this is just one more
step in that direction
just to say, hey, like, we
take this really seriously.
So we're opening our
region in London,
and we're also make
sure we're compliant.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: A second
cool thing of the week.
And this one, I
tweeted about it,
because as soon as
I saw it, I thought
it was really, really cool.
Our friends from
the New York Times.
And they were talking about
how to do continuous deployment
for App Engine and
Container Engine.
And they open source all of
the code, which is really cool.
MARK MANDEL: We'll link
to it in the show notes.
We'll find it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And now they open
sourced something else,
this time about Go.
It's about how to use
Go Kits on App Engine
standard environment,
so with Go 1.6
or Go 1.8 in beta currently.
MARK MANDEL: So for those who
don't know what Go Kit is--
I know I have a vague idea.
I'm not entirely sure--
why is Go Kit so cool?
And why is it cool that
it's on App Engine?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Go Kit basically,
it allows you to make
your services more robust.
It is a micro service
framework for Go.
And it manages things
like making sure
that you have
monitoring, and you're
able to instrument all your
endpoints and security,
and even things like,
well, if a server is down,
you should not keep on trying to
send requests all of the time.
So, like, [INAUDIBLE] backoff
and all of these things
that you need to
take care of when
you're writing a
robust architecture
with micro services.
All of those things are
available in Go Kit.
Now, the problem is that App
Engine has some limitations
on what you can do.
And one of them is actually
how you get an HTTP connection
to the outside.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So basically, they
adapted it so you can use App
Engine and Go Kit together,
which is really cool.
So if you're
interested, if you're
running Go on App
Engine, I'll definitely
ask you to go have a look,
because this is actually
really interesting stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Well, we
talked last week about
how Kubernetes 1.7 was released.
So this week, we're
talking about how you now
use it on Container Engine,
which is super, super cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
super, super fast.
MARK MANDEL: And
It's amazing how quickly
these come through.
As well as a couple of
other interesting things
in here just for GKE releases.
So we've got, like,
auto repair beta
for if nodes have any issues.
We have new regions and they
all have Container Engine,
which is great as well.
And we've also allowed us to
have internal load balancing
is beta as well for
Kubernetes and GKE
inside Google Cloud Platform.
So there's, like, a bunch of
new features that are also
available-- not just
Kubernetes' ones,
but GKE ones that have come
along with this release
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Really cool.
And the last cool thing of
the week before the interview
is about Container Builder.
And we did an episode
on Cointainer Builder.
It was episode 79.
And this time, we have a video
by one of our teammates, Carter
Morgan, talking about--
I think it's going to be
a long series because it's
called "Builder Part One."
But it's the first
of the series.
And htis one covers how
to do rolling updates
with Container Builder.
And it's only five minutes.
So if use any of these,
or if you're curious,
go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, I think that's
plenty of cool things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Why
don't we go chat
with our friends Lukas and Mike,
and talk all about platinum
customers and Broad Institute?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: Today, I am
delighted and overjoyed to have
two fine fellows
joining us today.
We have Lukas Karlsson, a
Cloud Architect and Developer
Advocate at Broad Institute.
And as well, we also
have Mike Altarace,
who is a Strategic Customer
Engineer here at Google Cloud
Platform as well.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
How are you both doing today?
Lukas?
LUKAS KARLSSON: Great.
Thank you for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Mike, you're doing well as well?
MIKE ALTARACE: Hey, guys.
Doing fantastic.
Thanks for asking.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you for coming.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So super excited to
have you on the podcast
to talk about both
Broad Institute,
and also being a platinum
customer and what
does that actually mean.
But before we do that, why don't
we just hear about both of you?
Lukas, why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself
and what you do at
the Broad Institute?
LUKAS KARLSSON: Well,
I've been at the Broad
for about 14 years or so.
So I've had quite a few
different roles over that time.
But right now, I'm responsible
for our cloud architecture
and strategy.
And I also am filling a role
as developer advocate, where
I try and improve the success
of all of the developers
within the Broad, and
some external, who try
to consume all of our services.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And for those that do not
know what it is, in, like,
a very short sentence, what
is the Broad Institute?
LUKAS KARLSSON: The brood is
a genomics research institute
funded primarily by
government grants
that focuses on the analytical
side of biology and chemistry.
So we were one of the
major contributors
responsible for the
Human Genome Project.
And now we are focused on
proving the value of the genome
by discovering
therapies and tools that
improve health and science.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That
And Mike, what do you do?
MIKE ALTARACE: Yes, hi.
I'm the Strategic
Customer Engineer
that actually is assigned
to the Broad Institute.
That's part of our
platinum support service
that we offer for
strategic customer.
Someone like myself, that
is assigned specifically
to a large customer
such as the Broad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you are a Googler?
MIKE ALTARACE: I'm a Googler.
I'm actually based out
of Reston, Virginia.
We are a worldwide team.
We have a presence
across the globe.
And I am here luckily
at the same time zone
as Lukas, on the East Coast.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right.
So Lukas, why don't we
start on the Broad Institute
side, and then we'll come
back to the platinum customer
side of things?
I'm sure we can find time
to switch in between.
But OK.
So it sounds like, Lukas, you
do a lot with very large amounts
of data.
Do you just run on GCP?
Like, what does
this pipeline look
like as you do these large
sort of-- sounds like data
calculations of some kind?
LUKAS KARLSSON: Well, we have a
really wide variety of projects
going on at the Broad.
So anything I say about what
we're doing for one project
is likely different
for some other project.
We have users in most of
the major public clouds
right now, including
Amazon and Google.
And certainly, data is probably
the biggest thing for us.
So when I look at our
consumption of services
in the cloud, more than
50% of what we consume
is data storage.
And probably a little over a
third of it is for compute.
And then everything else
is things like monitoring,
and SQL services, and
that sort of thing.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So what products
do you use on GCP?
LUKAS KARLSSON: So on
GCP we are, as I said,
a big storage customer.
We are using some of the global
and multi-regional and regional
buckets primarily,
although we're
sort of moving towards some
of the Nearline and Coldline
storage as well.
We do a massive
amount of compute--
parallel compute.
So we run jobs that at
times use, let's say,
tens of thousands of
CPUs simultaneously.
And so we're a big customer
of the preemptible VM service.
In fact, we were, I believe
Google's blog announcement
customer for that service.
MARK MANDEL: And so
just as an example,
what would you be
using these things for?
Like, you said you have a
wide variety of products.
But now I'm just quite curious,
like at a concrete level,
what you'd be doing.
LUKAS KARLSSON: So
the most common thing
that we do with computing
is we do data analysis.
So we have all these
instruments that
are sequencing
DNA and generating
various kinds of
raw data from images
to other sorts of data files.
And we run these
pipelines against them,
which basically looks like
potentially a Python script
or something that
reads in some raw data,
runs some Unix tools
against that data,
and then takes the output
from that first step
and makes that the
input of the next step.
And then, flowing through
a pipeline of steps
to generate some certain
kind of output that helps
answer some particular genetic
question about the data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So I guess since we have a--
I was going to say a
broad idea of the product.
Jokes.
Maybe we can talk a
little bit about the fact
that you mentioned that you
are a platinum customer.
What does this mean?
Maybe we can get Mike
to answer this question.
MIKE ALTARACE: Sure.
Yeah.
So a platinum customer
is a strategic customer
for Google Cloud Platform.
We deem those customers to
be of high importance to us
as a cloud provider.
And we want to make sure they
get the utmost experience
when it comes to using
Google Cloud Services.
And as part of that, to
make sure that that's really
happening is key.
A Strategic Customer Engineer
like myself is dedicatedly
assigned to those customers.
And in a way, we
are the constant
from the technical perspective
that they have in Google.
I'm like their
technical ambassador,
bridging all the different
groups within Google Cloud,
the PMs, the engineering,
the operationals, the TAM,
the sales, support itself.
And through those, providing
technical advisory, product
influence, and assistance
with operations.
So for example, as
Lukas mentioned,
there's a massive
amount of usage
when they kick up those
workloads as well.
We have teams
behind that are kind
of watching it and looking, and
making sure everything works
properly and as it should be.
And through our relationship
with Lukas-- myself
and engineering--
we are always kind
of making sure that these
things are ticking away
like they should be.
That's one example.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
now I'm curious about,
how are you different or similar
to CREs, Customer Reliability
Engineer?
MIKE ALTARACE: Yeah.
That's a fair question,
a very good one.
I guess the main
difference is that we
have an account-wide
relationship that
is continuous and constant.
I'm always going to be there.
Even if there is going to
be one or more CREs engaged,
there's always going
to be a SCE that
oversees the technical aspect of
the relationship between Broad
Institute and Google.
So no matter what,
anything that has
to be with technical aspect of
those relationships, the SCE
is going to be involved
and make sure everything
is moving in the right direction
and doesn't go orthogonal.
So either there are going to
be multiple engagements that
are in technical
nature through CREs,
through professional
services organizations.
But as a SCE, the
buck stops here
when it comes to technical
aspect of the relationship.
And I'm always going to be there
to make sure it's working out
the way it should.
MARK MANDEL: So
actually for two things.
Once, when you say
"ski," you mean an S-C.E.
That's just like--
MIKE ALTARACE: Exactly.
Carl, my manager, is the one
responsible for coming up
with the SCE acronym.
So we actually have a SCE Lodge
in the Mountain View office
with skis and fake snow.
And we try to name
all of our services
and all our offerings in
kind of like the ski-related.
So our weekly report
is called the Snowboard
MARK MANDEL: There's
a whole them.
No, that's fantastic.
MIKE ALTARACE: There's
a ski camp for--
LUKAS KARLSSON: Ours is
called the Broadcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The Broadcast.
That's very good.
MARK MANDEL: Oh wow.
Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I like puns.
I like it.
MARK MANDEL: Pun-tastic.
So Mike, you were talking about
having a continuous engagement.
What does that look like?
Do you have weekly meetings?
Are you in touch every day?
Does that work?
MIKE ALTARACE: Totally.
We have we have scheduled weekly
cadences across multiple teams
within the Broad.
Lukas, of course, is
a major part of it.
But it also means Hangouts,
and just ad hoc situations
where we just get on the Hangout
and chat and discuss things.
So if something needs
to be addressed,
either from operation, product
guidance, connecting to a PM,
I get hit by the Broad,
or I hit the Broad,
and we just have an impromptu
conversation about it.
The personal and the
trust relationship--
the trust aspect of
the relationship--
is key fact to what we
consider being a success
and in kind of making
sure everything works
and reducing their anxiety
about using the platform.
MARK MANDEL: So Lukas,
I was going to ask you--
and I think you're
about to jump in--
what does this look
like from your side?
LUKAS KARLSSON: Mike
has open office hours
that he provides via Hangout so
that anyone at the Broad who is
using GCP has access to Mike.
And in addition, we have
an internal Google group
of all of our GCP users
and an internal Slack
channel of the same users.
And Mike is involved
in both of those.
So many times, a user will
ask something in the chat room
or on the mailing list.
And the response is,
oh, Mike can help that.
Just reach out to Mike.
Or Mike will even
see these things
because he's periodically active
on these channels with us.
So he's very much integrated
as a member of our team--
an extended member of the
Broad's Google Support Team.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So that sounds awesome.
And I guess that
many of our customers
that are out there wondering,
how this does happen?
How did it start?
LUKAS KARLSSON: The way we got
onto GCP in the first place
is because we were already
a G Suite customer.
And as we began
moving into the cloud
and exploring the multiple
offerings out there,
you know, the G
Suite integration
with GCP, in that it's
using the same identities,
and we've already dealt with
the whole onboarding and
offboarding process of our users
so that, when someone leaves
the company and their G
Suite account is disabled,
that means they also lose access
to all of the GCP resources
that they would have had.
So that's been
compelling for us.
And that sort of is
one of the contributing
factors to us using GCP.
And certainly, over the
last four or five years
that we have been
a GCP customer,
our usage has grown
drastically over that time.
And sort of the
level of relationship
that we need to have in order
to be able to support that
has grown over that time.
So you know, I actually can't
imagine using the services
at the scale that
we use them today
without having Mike
involved at this point.
And it's hard for
me to remember what
it was like before we had him.
I don't really like
to think about it.
MARK MANDEL: So from
your side, Mike,
how did that look for you?
How did you get involved?
What was the onboarding
process for you?
MIKE ALTARACE: Yeah.
The tight relationship
between myself
as a SCE and the customer means
that the onboarding process
is almost like me doing a full
research about the customer,
their usage, reading up all the
internal documentation that we
had relating to the history
that we had with Broad
before me joining,
and just going
and drilling as deep as
possible around their usage,
their issues, their support
cases, the meeting notes.
Everything I could find
around the background
of Broad and Google
interaction, I
consumed it for a period of
time before I got engaged.
And of course, from that point
on, I was introduced to Lukas.
And slowly, as
time went by, I got
introduced to other
members of Broad Institute.
And as issues came up, that
was another opportunity
to learn even more and dig
even deeper about things
that they do.
In particular,
for example, Broad
is a big usage of
our Genomics API.
So through the Broad, I actually
got a lot of opportunity
to learn and understand
how our Genomics API works.
I got some data samples.
And I ran some of
the same workloads
that the Broad is running by
myself on our Genomics API
so I can get a better
understanding of how
the things that they do
operate on our side, all
the kind of pain points that
they're experiencing, so I can
provide better assistance
and better understanding when
things happen to how
to quickly make it
solved as quickly as possible.
LUKAS KARLSSON: And
then another thing
that Mike does that's
really helpful is he
sees all of the activity
on all of our tickets.
So even if it's, like, in
the middle of the night,
and I go and submit a ticket
about some issue I just
discovered, when I chat
with Mike in the morning,
he's certainly aware of that.
And it's not like I
have to bring him up
to speed on something
that just happened.
He has no full visibility
into everything.
So even times when
users within the Broad
submit tickets that
I don't know about,
Mike has visibility into that.
So he can sometimes
make me aware of issues
that I was not
aware of previously.
MIKE ALTARACE: And having that
additional context on the--
I guess almost like the
metadata on the fact
that Broad is a large customer,
and what they're doing,
and what are the typical
issues they have--
the ability to overlay
that, when issue comes up,
and communicate that to our
back end-- to engineering,
to support, to PMs, whoever--
makes the resolution and
the experience for the Broad
much better and much
more fluid than if it
has to be rediscovered
every time there's an issue.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
curious about you mentioning
that you're able to file issues,
and that you might get them
basically directly.
Are those issues filed the
same way as any other customer?
Is there a special
relationship that you have?
How does this work?
MIKE ALTARACE:
From the back end,
it's the same support
mechanism that all
of our other customers.
It's just the fact that I'm
tapped in right to the vein
of the Broad activity.
So I see that in real
time as it happened.
And if I find a place that
I can grease the skids,
so to speak, and make things
work a little bit more
smoother by providing
additional context,
I immediately get on that.
MARK MANDEL: Mike, should we
talk at all about the issue
tracker here, and how we have
additional visibility there.
MIKE ALTARACE: Yeah.
That's actually a
very good point.
So we actually, in addition
to just the general
support ticketing
system, we actually
also provision
Broad as a partner
to our internal
Buganizer system.
So Broad has a unique component
within Google's internal bug
tracking system, which is a way
to get even deeper penetration
and understanding
of technical issues
that are pertaining
to both sides.
So Broad can talk
directly to, for example,
Google Genomics API
engineers on specific issues
through the additional
system of the Buganizer.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm putting on
my hey-I'm-a-GCP-customer hat.
And I'm thinking to myself,
this sounds amazing.
I want what you all have.
How does that happen?
Is it a certain tier of usage?
Do we select based on
certain internal criteria?
What's the deal there, Mike?
MIKE ALTARACE: Yeah.
Great question.
So the SCE engagement
is actually
part of the professional service
organization of Google Cloud.
So any customer can actually
reach out to their Google Cloud
representative and ask
them about the option
of getting a technical
account manager, or a SCE.
We're making that
available as a service.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Is there a URL
that people can go
to if they want to find that?
Or is that specific to
you if you have already
had a sales agent?
MIKE ALTARACE: Yeah, absolutely.
So you can definitely
go to our website and go
to cloud.google.com/support.
And you should be able
to continue from there.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And we'll just hand
out your phone number,
Mike, if people can't find that.
Is that fine?
MIKE ALTARACE: Totally.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Cool.
MIKE ALTARACE: I'm used to that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm curious about,
is there any story
that you can share of,
like, how this actually
works, like a concrete use case
where being a platinum customer
solved a big problem?
Like I don't know if there
was some big technical problem
on your side, or I don't know--
like any kind of those issues
where being a platinum customer
really made a difference?
LUKAS KARLSSON: Yeah.
I mean, the ones I
like to talk about
are where we have
mistakenly exposed
the lack of infinite
capacity that Google has.
So, like, there
was that first time
where I got the
call where they were
like, what are you doing in
the central region right now?
And I was like, oh my gosh.
We just showed up
on Google's radar.
That's amazing.
And we realized
that there actually
are a limited
amount of resources,
and it's possible to consume
them all at some point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So now I'm wondering,
is there any story,
any interesting
story you can share,
that really shows
a big difference?
Like, oh, luckily, we're a
platinum customer that we're
able to solve this issue.
Is there something like that
that you can share that is not
top secret or something?
LUKAS KARLSSON: Yeah.
So one of the things I think
that one of the reasons we are
a platinum customer is
the scale at which we run
is such that we periodically
are able to expose
the fact that the cloud
is not actually unlimited.
So in one example, we
were using too many CPUs
in a particular
region, and we had
to be very strategic
with Google about where
to move those workloads.
There was another
situation last year
where we, in using all
of those preemptive VMs
that we were using,
we managed to consume
most of the IP address resources
in a particular region.
And so we went down a very
strategic route with Google
on not only tactically trying
to solve the immediate problem,
but basically trying to redesign
our application with Google
to make it so that we didn't
need to use so many external IP
addresses.
MARK MANDEL: And I assume--
I assume it wasn't, like, 5
or 10 CPUs or IP addresses.
It was a little
bit more than that?
LUKAS KARLSSON:
Tens of thousands.
So you know, one
of our applications
needs to speak to the internet.
And so while many of Google's
resources like storage
are available using
internal IP addresses,
if that same machine needs
to talk to, like, Docker hub,
for example, then it
or something near it
needs to have a public IP.
So we sort of exposed
this limitation
in both Google's
infrastructure, as well as
in the design of
our application.
And then Mike and his
team rallied around.
This was actually during
Docker Con last year.
And so there was a few
Googlers, like Mike's boss
Karl was at Docker Con.
And he and I were able to
get together in a little room
and just sort of hack
through the issue
with a bunch of Broadies who
were back on site in Cambridge,
and with Mike and others
who were online at Google.
And it was a really
collaborative, sort
of urgent effort to try
and resolve this issue.
MIKE ALTARACE: Just
from that point of view,
I mean, the back end
services and team owners
are intimately aware of
Broad Institute because
of issues like that.
And it actually helped us
make the platform better.
We changed a lot of
our internal processes,
and also general processes
as a cloud provider,
as a result of these
type of interactions
we had with the Broad Institute
being a platinum customer
and really pushing
us to the limit.
And at the end of
the day, it really
helps all of our customers.
LUKAS KARLSSON: Another
example, I think,
is Mike is able to help
me interact with many
of the PMs of some
of the products
that we rely on very heavily.
And through those
relationships, we're
often able to get on
early access or alpha
programs for certain products.
And for example, earlier this
year we were one of the first,
if not the first, customer
to begin using a feature.
And within the first day or
two of experimenting with it,
we found two major bugs.
And so Google was able to
sort of pull that feature,
resolve those bugs,
and get that redeployed
before any other
customers experienced it.
So in the end, we were
able to get access
to a feature that
was critical to us,
and we were able to help
Google make that feature more
reliable for everybody.
MIKE ALTARACE: And at the end,
taking that to the next level,
as a result of all
the tight interaction
we had around that feature
and functionality, Lukas
was actually on the
Next 2017 on stage
presenting some of
the code that he
wrote related to that
functionality and feature.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
Nice.
MIKE ALTARACE: The fact
that they're building up
their content and requirement
for GCP Next, Lukas
immediately came to mind.
And through the
relationship, we were
able to reach out and work
out a way where Lukas ends up
on stage talking
about the solution.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
We'll find that
talk and we'll have
a link from the show notes.
That's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So we're running out
of time, and so I
like to ask my favorite
question, which is, does anyone
have anything to
add, or anything
we haven't managed to ask in
our interview process so far?
Mike, I think you
might have something.
MIKE ALTARACE: Yeah.
Thanks.
So last point.
I do actually have the URL where
you can go and get in touch
with the professional services.
And it's
cloud.google.com/solutions.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right.
Lukas, Mike, thank you
so much for joining us.
We really appreciate
you taking the time
and talking to us
about Broad Institute,
and also what it means to
be a platinum customer.
LUKAS KARLSSON:
Thanks for having us.
MIKE ALTARACE: Thank you guys.
Pleasure to be here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So thanks
again to both Lukas and Mike
for taking the time today
to explain a little bit
about what it is to be a
platinum customer, what
does it entail, and what is
the relationship, and how,
basically, helping each
other all the time.
Pretty amazing that
platinum customers,
they get such a
level of support.
Like, they basically you
can call someone, a Googler,
on their mobile phone directly.
Pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And make sure, if you have a
company that's large enough
or have enough
needs that you think
you need to be a
platinum customer,
check out the links
in the show notes
so that you can get involved
as quickly as possible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I guess that it's
time to go with a
question of the week.
And as I was saying at the
beginning of the episode,
this one comes from
someone that came
to see me at the Google Cloud
Platform booth at GopherCon
last week in Denver.
And his question was like,
OK, so I have a development
cluster for Kubernetes.
So basically, I'm running
Kubernetes on GKE.
And it's a development
QA thing, so I
want it to be as
cheap as possible
because there's no production
traffic going on in there.
So I don't really care about
reliability or anything
like that.
So I can run it with
one single instance.
And I can even run it with
[INAUDIBLE] more, which is
actually very, very affordable.
But then, when I want
to expose service,
if I expose it with the
default way of doing it,
which is by saying type
is not load balancer,
then all of a sudden,
you get a load balancer.
And then you need to pay for
that load balancer, which
is more than what they would
like to pay, specifically
for this test environment.
So how can you expose service
without a load balancer?
And I think that you
have a way to do it.
So I guess you can go with one,
and I'll go with the other one.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
I have one way that
I think should work.
So the way that I
was going to say--
so we're saying
that there's one--
we're going to have one instance
in our Kubernetes cluster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
often, what happens
if you're not running
Kubernetes in the cloud,
rather than using a service
with a type load balancer,
you often do what's called type
node port, which actually opens
up the port directly
on the machine.
And it opens up the same
port for all the services
across all the machines that
are inside your cluster.
So then you could put your own
load balancer over the front.
Just point it to those
ports across those machines
and you're good to go.
But there's nothing that
stops you from saying,
hey, why don't we
just connect directly
to that node port for
that individual service?
So you could do a
service with a node port,
specify the port that
you want to open,
and have that available.
The only caveat I
would put is just
to make sure that there is a
firewall rule on that Compute
Engine instance that
GKE provisions for you
to ensure that the traffic
will go through to that port.
But in theory, it should work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I guess there's
a second caveat to that, which
leads us to the other solution,
which is, what happens
if that instance is restarted?
You might get a different IP.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So all of a sudden,
what IP should you target?
So that's why there's a
different solution, which
is by using static IPs.
So you can get a static
IP for your service.
And then that static IP, it
is completely free of charge,
as long as it's
assigned to something.
So if you're running it with
an instance, then you're good.
You don't need to
pay for anything
for that one, which is cool.
And then you can actually
set, on your ingress service,
you can set that specific IP.
The details to set this up are
actually part of a little repo
that Kelsey Hightower
open sourced.
So we will have a link
to that specific place
that basically takes you through
how to reserve a static IP,
and then how to add it to your
Kubernetes' configuration files
in order to use that
one for your service
rather than allocating
a new load balancer.
MARK MANDEL: If you
wanted to get super fancy,
you might be able to make
it preemptible as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I tried, and you can.
I don't know.
I mean, it will be
more affordable.
But at the same time, I wonder
if you're running tests on it--
MARK MANDEL: But it's only going
to go down maybe once every 24
hours or so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or more.
MARK MANDEL: So it's not
going to happen that often.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's going
to make your tests flaky,
so then you need to
rerun them again.
MARK MANDEL: You
have to rerun them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But at the same
time, it's integration tests..
So probably, flakiness is OK.
MARK MANDEL: I'm just
saying it's an option.
It's there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
definitely an option.
The one that is not an
option that I thought about
was, well, if I want to make
it as affordable as possible,
maybe I can run an F1
micro because you get one
for free per month.
So that would be perfect.
But it is not enough to run
Kubernetes, unfortunately.
So you need to run at
least F1 small, which
is also very, very, very
affordable, to be honest.
MARK MANDEL: So you can run
Kubernetes, but no paths.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Basically, yeah.
You can run Kubernetes, but
nothing will run inside.
So yeah.
Not big enough.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right.
Before we ramble on
even further, Francesc,
what are you up to?
Are you going anywhere special?
I know you just got
back from GopherCon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I just got back from
GopherCon, so I'm
taking a couple days off.
My goal, camping somewhere
in the forest far away
from computers.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And after that, basically,
enjoying San Francisco.
I'll be here for the Go
SF meetup on July 26.
And after that,
[INAUDIBLE] again.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: What am I up to?
Let me think.
So I will be
attending-- actually,
so I will be speaking at
Pax Dev at the end of August
in Seattle, and then
attending Pax after that.
So that'll be lots
and lots of fun.
Before that, I think just
getting ready for Pax.
I'm pretty excited
about it, actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I guess that I will also
mention that I keep on releasing
"Just for Func" episodes.
MARK MANDEL: Just for Func.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by the
time this episode comes out,
I will be working
on the next one.
And there are some
surprises coming up,
like guest stars
and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
going to be exciting.
Yep.
MARK MANDEL: I'm excited.
Wonderful.
Well, Francesc, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And enjoy the amazing
weather in New York,
as you love it so much.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]